[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la precampaña francesa muy animada a
menos de 5 meses de esas selecciones de
esa carrera por el elíseo nos acompañan
en este estudio beatriz juez
corresponsal del diario 'el correo' aquí
en francia de bienvenida de drift nadie
los comete y periodista política
bienvenida lo es y él vivieron ruth ya
politólogo de asesor en management
político bienvenido alivien hola gracias
la batalla por el elíseo 2022 hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
la elección de la candidata conservadora
a las elecciones presidenciales de abril
del año que viene en francia- valérie
pécresse la semana pasada viene a
completar el cuadro de candidatos que
disputarán al presidente manuel macro en
la presidencia de francia un macro
aunque todavía no anunciado que presentó
oficialmente su candidatura ante es algo
que se da ya por hecho y por descontado
con la derecha intentando buscar su
espacio con una izquierda más
desdibujada que nunca y con una nueva
ultraderecha la del polemista eric
zemmour fenómeno político de los últimos
meses en francia el trans francés
condenado en varias ocasiones por
incitación al odio demuestra eso sí que
es producto de un malestar que arrastra
este país desde hace tiempo repasemos
algunas portadas que nos deja la prensa
diario libération portada con todos los
candidatos reservando una sombra en el
centro para macrón que aún no ha
oficializado el diario habla de
sobrecalentamiento tras los altercados
en el primer mitin de eric samur el
pasado fin de semana le figaro pécresse
lanza la batalla contra macrón dice el
diario conservador que pécresse tiene
ahora el reto de aunar todas las
sensibilidades de la derecha republicana
en torno a su candidatura
y la aparición se pregunta por su parte
si el fenómeno samur no se va a
desinflar como ya da muestras de algunos
signos de fatiga y varios tropiezos en
estas últimas semanas bueno el ambiente
hayas de precampaña beatriz quedan cinco
meses pero no sé si podemos ya ir
definiendo algunas líneas que vayan
definiendo ya esta precampaña en francia
bueno esta última semana ha sido también
muy interesante y muy animada porque
como ha cambiado un poco todo no de
repente ha salido p crees la líder de la
derecha que en un principio no no era
favorita para ganar luego y por fin
fémur después de varios de varios meses
por fin ha anunciado su candidatura y
ahora nos hemos visto también a la
izquierda anida algo que la pobre sólo
tiene un 3% en las encuestas sería y ha
querido hacer una unión de la izquierda
y llamado nos espera un llamado
desesperado y no la salida entonces todo
está ocurrido en una semana y se ha
puesto todo bastante emocionante
algunas tendencias que ya podamos ir
viendo de esta precampaña electoral
parece que ahora ya conocemos casi todos
los candidatos y que de manera macro
bomba
a esperar y tardar mucho en anunciar su
probable candidatura y va a aprovechar
de este período en donde bueno es
presidente está a cargo y no tiene que
salir a anunciarlo con lo que todos
suponemos si puede puede aprovechar a
realmente de este momento además con la
presidencia francesa del consejo de la
unión europea
aguantar digamos esa imagen de hombre de
estado lo máximo que puede quedarse por
popa por encima de la pelea o libia
algunas tendencias que podemos ver ya de
esta precampaña sino sobre todo la
victoria de varias y pecas en las primas
reales de derecha que según mi punto de
vista esto sí que cambia realmente el
juego porque es de su candidatura ya era
algo bastante esperado desde las últimas
seis semanas o meses se intuía no mucho
y en cuanto al estancamiento del voto de
izquierda pues es algo también que no ha
cambiado en las últimas semanas pero la
entrada de píxeles sí que ya es una
novedad yo creo que bastante importante
es el elemento nuevo luego vamos a
comentar vamos a analizar la figura de
crees pero en cualquier caso estamos
hablando de macrón en el centro liberal
estamos hablando de las candidaturas de
la ultraderecha con zemour estamos
hablando de la elección de pécresse
beatriz estamos hablando de una elección
que gravitan en la derecha sí sí
claramente porque la izquierda están
todos divididos y bueno si se unieran
cosas que ya hemos visto que no va a
pasar
podían tener una opción para pasar o
tendrían como el 24 por ciento podrían
pasar a la segunda vuelta pero como
están todos unidos el máximo tiene un 8%
de intención de votos
pues claramente
es esta gira a la derecha de esta
campaña pero siempre yo creo que también
se aquí en francia es un país muy
comparado con otros países
y siempre ha habido la perspectiva lo
que no hay ni siquiera esta vez es la
perspectiva de intentar luchar por la
primera vuelta que yo creo que eso es la
novedad que ni siquiera existe esa
perspectiva sí creo que sí es histórico
no que con una izquierda izquierda tan
tan débil y además bueno la izquierda no
logra imponer sus temas o sea bueno hubo
un momento en el que hemos hablado de
poder adquisitivo un poco de ecología
cuando hubo la primera la primaria de
los ecologistas en septiembre pero
realmente los temas que se imponen en el
debate público no son temas para la
izquierda y hoy o sea la izquierda
podría
hablar de sus temas de inmigración e
inseguridad autoridad orden pero no lo
hace o cuando lo hace es un fracaso
porque miren lo que pasó con nando
monbús que quiso bueno quiso proponer
una medida un poco fuerte un poco
provocativa sobre inmigración y bueno me
dio mira de su equipo de campaña si fue
un desastre o libia tenemos una agenda
de temas de seguridad del encaje del
islam en francia que son temas que la de
izquierda se sienten incómodos
tratándolo y a la vez los temas
prioritarios de la izquierda como la
ecología como posición social no
consigue meterlos en la agenda
a ver es verdad que es la primera vez en
toda la historia de la quinta república
que las fuerzas de izquierda están tan
débiles en cuanto a posibilidad de votos
no creo que es tan chico como lo dijo
beatriz en un 24 25 porque son todo lo
mismo que macrón swan a la izquierda
todas las que se suman lo quemaron
sí yo creo que tanto es tanto un
problema de personalidad de los que
representan ahora mismo la corriente
progresista en francia como un problema
también si programático no es decir que
ahora hay temáticas que son temáticas
digamos que hablan al cotidiano francés
es que la izquierda por un motivo u otro
no ha querido tratar con lo cual existe
una especie de desconexión entre las
preocupaciones de los ciudadanos con lo
que propone y lleva la izquierda en el
debate público y eso yo creo explica
mucho el desmoronamiento de la izquierda
hay una desconexión beatriz entre la
izquierda de ciudadanos en francia
porque en estos momentos mucha gente
está preocupada por no por temas estos
de inmigración de seguridad del islam o
de la integración de los de los
musulmanes en la sociedad y esos temas
no los trata generalmente la izquierda o
nuestra tampoco de lado porque
históricamente ha habido
si ha habido partidos de izquierda en la
historia que han hablado de seguridad
que han hablado de la inmigración que
han hablado es la izquierda de ahora el
propio partido comunista francesa con 2
marc se hablaba mucho de inmigración y
del encaje de los extranjeros dentro de
la economía francesa porque lo veía como
un peligro justamente para los la clase
obrera francesa que llegase demasiada
inmigración económica y que los grandes
las grandes empresas pues se
aprovechasen de esa inmigración como
para controlar a la baja los sueldos de
los obreros entonces eso sí que era una
forma de izquierda de tratar de un
problema social que se provea de la
inmigración pero desde una perspectiva
de izquierda
sigue hablando de inmigración en esos
términos más o menos pero
antes estaba también la figura de manuel
valls
lo hizo que también lo hizo pero bueno
luego acabó mal también este el es en la
propia izquierda llamaban a vance
racista facha reaccionario como si una
persona izquierda no pudiese tratar de
temáticas que son temáticas digamos
totalmente compartidas por todo el mundo
es decir que no es la temática la que
define el ser de izquierda o derecha es
la perspectiva con la que se con la que
se trata la temática lo que define nos
hace bien a pasar lo mismo cuando por
ejemplo una señora conservadora se
declara feminista que hay gente que
intenta como atizar la en ese carnet por
definirse de esa forma linda no sé si
sería un ejemplo en el redes contrario
que se puede pasar
macrón llega al momento de su reelección
con buenos datos económicos y una
popularidad mejor que en otros momentos
de su quinquenio donde los movimientos
sociales se lo pusieron muy complicado
si recuerdan el caso de los chalecos
amarillos o de las huelgas todavía no
anunciado su candidatura y juega con ese
rol de presidente del consejo de la
unión europea a partir de enero que
francia va a presidir en el primer
semestre del año
europa va a ser su gran que evidenciar
su gran baza para estas elecciones la
gris y yo creo que sí porque más el el
se define como europeísta
y además es y eso le diferencia también
a mejor más de otros de otros candidatos
con más de la extrema derecha que
siempre arremeten contra europa y él va
a estar haciendo un montón de reuniones
por aquí por francia
trayendo a todos los ministros trayendo
a todos a todos los presidentes y primer
ministros de aquí aquí en francia
reuniones y va a tener una proyección
por internacional como un hombre de
estado un hombre europeo además ahora ya
no está merkel
entonces él puede aprovechar esta baza
no lo único que luego veremos si suma o
resta
como lo hace si se pasa demasiado o no
veremos si sumó resta puntos aquí en lo
que se las elecciones no
no sé cómo va a compaginar este juego de
roles de un presidente del consejo de la
unión europea y al mismo tiempo estar en
campaña visitando lugares de la francia
profunda que recelan un poco de la
figura del propio macrón claro pero me
parece que
durante su quinquenio marco ha mostrado
que le gusta no esté estaremos a navegar
entre dos aguas y lo hace de manera como
sea controlada y me parece que
lo habíamos visto cuando durante la
campaña la carrera para la elección
europea porque bueno era presidente y
había dicho no voy a entrar en la
carrera pero bueno había recorrido a
francia para para para sostener su
partido entonces sí pienso como como
dice beatriz que va a aprovechar de esta
presidencia para mandar mensajes y
tratar de porque ya ha dicho que su
proyecto para la presidencia la
presidencia francesa de la del consejo
europeo era bueno hacer reformas
sociales sobre la inmigración y estos
son son temas que van se van a imponer
en la carrera presidencial
la reforma del espacio schengen para
fortalecer las fronteras que es un tema
que también es un tema que liga mucho
con la campaña aquino de europa es un
tema fundamental para el electorado de
natrón lo que no sé si es peligroso esta
dicotomía que pretende siempre macro
dónde yo soy el europeísta y en frente a
estas elecciones lo que hay enfrente es
el nacionalismo y es o esto o yo
europeísta o el nacionalismo esa especie
de dicotomía en la que con la que macro
no intenta presentarse en las elecciones
no si es peligroso reincidir en ello
tanto olivia ha sido su fuerza en las
últimas elecciones en su mandato y
también puede ser su fracaso tal es un
juego peligroso es una apuesta pero yo
creo que ya es demasiado tarde para él
como para cambiar de chip no porque
ahora asumir un discurso que no fuese
totalmente europeísta con todo lo que
hizo no sería creíble me van a permitir
unos segundos para una pausa y enseguida
volvemos aquí en primera plana gracias
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellos hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
porque la historia se escribe día a día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia
todos los temas para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente liberté
égalité actual y ti
continuamos en primera plan esta semana
analizando la precampaña en francia que
está siendo realmente vibrante lo
hacemos con beatriz juez oliver urrutia
y lo cometí estábamos hablando antes de
ir a la pausa de la figura de manuel
macro de cómo se presenta el presidente
para la reelección no ha oficializado su
candidatura pero desde luego es algo que
ya está todo el mundo por sentado los
sondeos le otorgan esa primera plaza dan
por descontado que ultraderecha y
conservadores se jugarán la segunda
plaza para el balotaje lo hoy en día con
los sondeos que tenemos y la exclusión
tenemos parece lo más probable pero pasa
que cambiaría muchos escenario no de
macrón frente a la ultraderecha o de
mccrone frente a p crees que es la
candidata conservadora no son los dos
escenarios que ahora mismo más más
probables pero bueno hay que ver cómo va
a
evolucionar la extensión y también hay
que mirar qué bueno lo en los sondeos se
ve que se puede ver que los electos
electores son muy inciertos no inseguros
o sea creo que he visto que 40 post por
ciento de los electores que dicen hoy y
no están seguros segurísimos de votar
para ello en abril así que bueno hombre
regresa ahora mismo tienen subidos los
sondeos digamos porque también tiene el
efecto este de haber salido no hay que
esperar un poco para ver una radiografía
más real de lo que está pasando con él
todavía no han presentado su programa
entonces bueno hay que que esperar un
poco pero hoy en día claro que son los
dos escenarios más probables
si fuera macro contra la ultraderecha la
pregunta que se me viene a la mente es
que ultraderecha la del pp o la de fémur
en que sea diferencia en ambas olivia en
que se diferencian las ultraderechas
porque ahora ya hablamos de las
ultraderechas en francia en pocas cosas
yo creo porque al fin y al cabo decimos
mismo
él mismo ha
enfocado las diferencias con lópez sobre
todo en un tema de personalidad y sobre
todo de capacidad de liderazgo
pero menos en cuestiones programáticas
es decir que ese modo se presenta como
la alternativa más creíble imagine el
open para que la ultraderecha llegue a
gobernar pero no por cuestiones digamos
de fondo político sino más bien de
capacidad personal entonces grandes
diferencias como si las hay pequeñas
pero no grandes diferencias si se
dividen más o menos el mismo electorado
de hecho son un poco los vasos
comunicantes no porque cuando uno sube
el otro baja enseguida es el mismo
electorado entonces la fuerza es que el
que gana se va a llevar casi todo el
voto del otro pero de momento es un poco
como la izquierda se están dividiendo el
mismo voto hay un peligro de que ninguno
de los dos llega a la segunda vuelta en
frente de mango pero también la
diferencia respecto a otras
presidenciales es que una vez que llegan
a la segunda vuelta si llega uno de los
dos el otro va a recibir una reserva de
votos que nunca ha tenido de la
ultraderecha bastante importante
y parte del voto de pace los de 7 el que
estaba enfrente y page que es muy
cercano a the move entonces esa reserva
de votos también podría pasar a al
candidato de ultraderecha mi compañera
beatriz juez estuvo el fin de semana
pasado el domingo en el primer meeting
de zemour por ser tu mitin en el que
hubo muchos altercados luego les quiero
preguntar si esto puede enrarecer la
campaña a partir de ahora pero lo
primero beatriz quiénes son los votantes
de por qué te encontraste en aquel
pabellón de bill evans quiere quienes
había allí jaime me sorprendió que había
mucha gente joven plan no sea gente de
18 años veintitantos muchas mucha mucha
gente joven y también cosa si lo
comparas por ejemplo con un mitin de del
epen que normalmente son gente mayor
y por ejemplo también me
me sorprendió que no se le veía que
fuesen clases populares más bien en
gente de clase media media-alta
hombres y señoras del del distrito 16 de
parís que es uno de los más caros y
elegantes y
pues que habían ido a allí también a
verle y luego también pues había gente
que había votado me habían dicho que
habían votado a otras adiciones a
sarkozy o habían votado por lepe pero
que de peña no les convencía porque la
veían como ya que haya pasado que su
oportunidad en 2017 había pasado y
entonces ahora buscaban como una novedad
algo nuevo y de moore es un poco pues la
novedad entonces muchos pues les gusta
por eso porque también no tiene pelos en
la lengua ting de cosas que antes la
gente no se atrevía a decir
y que muchos piensan entonces pues les
parece es un candidato para que nos
entiendan nuestros oyentes y
telespectadores de américa latina muchas
veces de hacer la comparativa entre
fémur y donald trump o se habla del
trans francés refiriéndose a fémur en
que se parecen aunque se diferencian
hasta qué punto está bien hecho o mal
hecha esta comparativa lo que parece
claro es que ambos dominan muy bien el
lenguaje mediático y lo que son las
audiencias y ambos saben manejar este
tipo de lenguaje televisivo muy bien
bueno él viene de la televisión es un
ensayista aún
un cronista en la televisión francesa
desde hace ni siquiera cuento los años
pero conocen muy bien los medios sabe
exactamente
cómo es y cómo manejar su comunicación y
bueno y
maneja bien también el tema de bueno le
provocará las provocaron ser cosas
virales y bueno por ahí se puede comprar
un poco cuando donald trump pero creo
que el paisaje francés es muy diferente
al paisaje político americano
yo comparto totalmente yo creo que hay
una tentación existe una tentación en el
campo decimos de copiar a la figura y
con no ser muy instructivo para
justamente pues captar el voto de toda
esa gente que considera la clase
política francesa tradicional desgastada
lo que pasa que en francia los eeuu
desesperó y los franceses no son los
estadounidenses parece un turismo pero
es verdad y con lo cual el peligro yo
creo para hace mucho es justamente
copiar demasiado a camps que es lo que
no le gusta al electorado francés que es
mucho más clásico tradicional en los
modos
que en eeuu hay dos partidos y tram
tenía detrás el partido republicano y
el fémur un acaba de formar su partido
que se llama reconquista que es un
nombre muy bien
aparte de eso no tiene un partido detrás
aunque bueno aquí macrón ganó ganó
creando un partido nuevo que nunca se
sabe pero también tiene la fuerza
trump de que el partido republicano que
es una máquina de hacer elecciones y de
ganar elecciones y él es nuevo
lcd pécresse como líder conservadora es
más perjudicial electoralmente para
macro no para la ultraderecha olivia
parra bajo parámetros claramente
claramente es la
la líder que no quería tener una gran en
frente yo creo que no se lo esperaba
como mucha gente no se lo esperaba pero
yo creo que sí que es un problema
importante para él porque ella sí que
ocupa un espacio político bastante
interesante que no es exactamente el
mismo que él aunque sí un poco centro
derecha pero también intentando guardar
dentro de su dinámica al voto digamos de
la derecha conservadora un poco más
reaccionaria que podría estar tentada
por
sumarse a los votos desde mucho y de iu
del open pero sí peques consigue no
defender toda esa dinámica que agrupa de
la derecha conservadora hasta la derecha
del centro pues sí que podría amenazar
seriamente a la reelección de macri es
ese espacio que los republicanos llevan
buscando desde la elección de macrón y
todavía no lo habían encontrado
lo que llamamos la síntesis
makoun y es lo que intenta hacer es que
es un club de macul
tienen el mismo perfil a pocos años
diferencia ella también es una novedad
aunque lleva muchos años en política
pero no a este nivel aunque fue ministra
es también en arca tecnócrata como mac o
muy buena gestora de la región
es síntoma del oportunismo político del
señor mattis moya malone como quieren de
poder ser camaleónico palpar la sociedad
más o menos o quiénes son tus votantes y
poder ir cambiando un poco esto es muy
poco romántico poco importante biología
sino más bien ir moviendo los hilos
según donde puedas pescar no eso lo
tienen igual totalmente porque ella de
momento consigue prometer al electorado
edición súper reaccionario conservador a
la vez consigue prometer al electorado
de bani y de ex a que viajó mucho más
moderado como consiga
defender esa posición de síntesis yo
creo que podría ganar y ella ha dicho
que dos tercios merkel un tercio
thatcher un poco
yo soy de derechas de verdad y luego me
gusta mucho una reacción de milán son
que él siempre es muy
buenas salidas que decía no lo en
realidad pécresse es dos tercios macrón
un tercio de moore
que qué bueno que ese suelo que como si
ella ella va a intentar parecer de
derecha ser dos tercios merkel en un
tercio
thatcher pero mucha gente lo va a ver
como que es un macro un abismo que
también me decían muchos en el congreso
no que es un macro físico y que no hay
que votar por ella el partido ecologista
fue vencedor por consenso de las últimas
municipales y los dos partidos
históricos aguantaron el poder en las
regionales pero fíjense esto hace nada
pero la coyuntura actual hace pensar que
en francia cada elección se rige por
parámetros muy distintos no sí parece
que sí pero bueno creo que esto siempre
ha existido en qué
los franceses no votan igual
si es para para elegir su alcalde o su
presidente de región o su presidente del
país no los niveles de abstención varían
o sea fluctúan mucho y también los
electorados nos van a votar de las
mismas elecciones la gente y sobre todo
las clases populares que en general no
votan mucho en las elecciones europeas o
en las elecciones regionales pero si van
a votar un poco más a la presidencial
por ejemplo así que sí tuvimos un cóctel
de resultados electorales muy muy
sorprendente pero hay que si hay que
guardar cuando muchos pensaban que el
ecologismo iba a seguir después de las
municipales y se iba a presentar en las
presidenciales de momento la verdad es
que esta trayectoria esa dinámica no la
estamos viendo
pero el régimen francés es un régimen
presidencialista como el de la quinta
república con lo cual siempre si se dice
que las elecciones a la presidencia es
el encuentro entre uno personalidad y el
pueblo los ciudadanos con lo cual yo
creo que hacer un debate sobre las
diferencias programáticas no es tan
importante hay que ver sobre todo la
capacidad de liderazgo a nivel personal
de cada uno de los candidatos y ahí los
ecologistas pues pecan o no tienen una
figura y súper potente dentro del
paisaje político francés me queda un
minuto así que ronda rápida y pido que
se mojan hoy si tuviese que apostar
quienes se colaran en la segunda vuelta
de las presidenciales ese duelo sería
entre rápido vea macro pécresse en
background en el bien el real madrid
para la liga de campeones y macu y que
ésta no se arriesga de decirlo macro
pécresse
bueno pues nada tomamos nota invitamos a
café es el 25 de abril el 5 de abril
invitamos a café bueno no antes desde el
10 de abril ya conoceremos los
resultados de esa segunda vuelta ha sido
un placer contar con ustedes en esta
primera plana sobre la precampaña
electoral francesa y a todos ustedes les
esperamos la próxima semana aquí en
radio francia internacional y france
gracias
[Música]